that's going nobody's doing why is your
neck like that we have Leia here aka the
cute little girl from record wealth that
we can't remember her name
hi
you're smiling today hi eyes are so I
know
nevermind don't don't talk about her
eyes so big
[Music]
I know it's like a spitting image she's
starting to look like a girl duh
what do you mean alright so we are going
hiking today with nantan Cristina and
Leia Leah's first hike we're so special
we get to go on her first hike with with
the wait we get to go with her yeah Ella
p1 sweet is that
that's the record Ralf character Leia
looks like sarah silverman voice you see
why we didn't remember that name that's
such a complicated black Karen you're in
the same vanellope has a candy in your
hair that's gotta be her first Halloween
costume this coming year oh and then
Anne could be you Ralph oh yeah the guy
the plumbery guy or whatever that's
wrong oh the other guy and the good guy
the guy in the blue oh yeah
does the energy being a bad guy never
finished
tired I how do you feel back here daddy
you should you should actually feel very
proud of your daddy I'm tired
are you really which we haven't gotten
to the park edge so that is okay but you
did the Spartan Race we should have just
parked by the freeway in came all right
so we're complaining about being tired
but we haven't gotten inside the actual
trail yet they ran out of parking so he
parked on the street in the residential
area back there so why not are we so
lazy
well I'm just I mean yeah it's really me
he's really good about being athletic
and like working out and making his
blood pumping like all that stuff and I
used to Train like weight training at
barbell years ago but I haven't gone
back I just didn't like it I got to go
back into being active somehow this is a
good start out as you're trying to make
it sound like you're not out of breath
this is good just getting to the
entrance of the starting Aras go home
all right we're finally in the park
we're not over now that was literally
the entrance maybe it's like the
jurisdiction part or it's just that's
the line to cross but we're still got a
long way to go I'm running ahead so I
can get some shots of them walking yeah
there's a blind corner so mamma
Christina gave me some bars cuz I forgot
to have breakfast this morning she was
like don't worry girl I'm a mom I got
you and she's good she pulled these out
thank you son wake up and see the world
hey it's not working
finally made it into the trail after how
long have you been hiking already did a
parking mile over a mile know how long
that mile took this
[Music]
she think that she's talking to you but
she's probably pooping
thanks for killing it really the morning
the moment I mean I'm just doing a dad
you know when he's pooping cuz she goes
I think it was so funny when he was a
baby he would do this little thing with
his mouth do you feel like every time he
poops and I always knew in his movie
because he would make some weird face
that's funny
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I think we're walking around the
area now that we did that once get where
Bart with a girl or something and then
Joe was like or maybe there it was like
falling down the cliff he was like the
Rope is about to yeah like here we threw
a dummy down from up from up there oh
yeah something over here I don't know I
can't remember it nature all looks the
same
[Music]
that Mina button is no this is no place
you look so comfortable on your pajama
looking outfit that's not pajamas how
many moms does it take to feed a baby
three one two three four you're too tiny
baby you got to get bigger all right
let's get this on yeah well don't fight
it come on it's only two ounces it's
only two ounces half full oh you like to
take breaks in between your eating she
does it takes her an hour to an hour and
a half to finish a bottle whoa how many
ounces uh uh
like four ounces how long did it take
Isaac before we need feed oh well I
would nurse him oh yeah I wouldn't know
how many ounces he was getting really
but he would eat maybe like 20 minutes
okay
[Music]
[Music]
just shows you like how the drought
affects everything it's actually bigger
than before before is just like a little
stream and now we had a little rain and
it's got that so it looks pretty good so
Leia and I are having a moment at the
waterfall why are you staring at me
making me uncomfortable
no no looking at boys hey stop looking
up that's right let's see if you can
make us laugh all right make a laugh
here we go three two one
usually that would make her laugh
tonight too much going on right now I
think she's
what happened started closing your eyes
when you touched it I bought her to
sleep
oh you did and that's a good thing for
us oh yeah a good test a boring stay for
yes hone this yes and then we're going
to be very well rested yeah yeah
[Music]
how was the waterfall free it was
magnificent
yeah kidding no it's uh I mean that's
pretty its nature but I think I got
spoiled by the Hawaiian waterfalls
there's like so sad yeah the fact that
we go to other places for their nature
when you come back to California a SoCal
specifically in LA specifically
beautiful I think SoCal is great for two
things it's great for the weather
because it's constantly in 270 degrees
fahrenheit range so it feels like Austin
you know a seas blowing in nature that's
number one that's cool - we get a
variety of everything so we got forests
you got mountain we got Beach we got
desert we got just about a little bit of
everything but it's also just buffet
quality when it comes to the nature
elements good it's not the greatest
mountain is not the greatest for ski
areas quality yeah we can even say Las
Vegas buffet quality still it's okay
it's good yes now it's if you want to
stay good you go two three four so you
go to you know something like that
[Music]
I almost tripped on that thank God I
checked I was watching that one hasn't
watching hands they're a little missing
[Music]
take a step you can do it yesterday so
[Music]
[Applause]
precious you guys made this star Jackie
oh baby thank you I can't stop saying
how cute
[Music]
she almost said bye all right so we had
a healthy morning yes we did healthy
lunch yes we did totally got the itis
after eating home just like us and then
looking at Leia she looks so comfortable
feeling like oh girl I want to be on the
same trip right there I'm just I'm ready
for some sleep
[Music]
[Music]